ce retour vers la glace tous bien
maintenant on est encore plus entre nous
dans la voiture il ya une phrase qui
revenait souvent les femmes sont toutes
des [ __ ] est ce que vous pensez
réellement les femmes non dur quand tu
dis les femmes sont toutes des [ __ ]
tu l'as dit souvent ça les femmes sont
non je le dis avec tout le monde bien
sûr dans la voiture mais c'est une
phrase toute faite mais c'est pas je ne
pense pas profondément parce que bien à
c'est évident un mais
c'est beau une généralité encore une
fois est-ce que tu respectes les femmes
j'ai ouï je les respecte c'est plutôt
tendance à les respecter
jusqu'ici toujours est-ce que tu les
sifflets ce que tous les agrès c'est ce
que tu les dracs 3 souvent est-ce que tu
les embête
non j'ai tendance à aller regarder enfin
si c'est une agression que de regarder
une femme
certaines bonnes hier la minijupe quant
aux récollets à billie joe de campsas
transparent pas de soutien gorge parce
que ça c'est un côté qui prend tout cela
tu m'as dit souvent qu'elle aimait ça
lui en font elles aiment ça ils aiment
se faire violer
non j'ai élargi un petit peu
elle aime se faire violer
non je charrie pas j'ai pas dit qu elle
n est fait à violer allemand elles
provoquent elles provoquent souvent le
viol mais un viol qui n'est pas un viol
physique qui est un viol
qui ont moral non mais tu parlais de
duels physiques quand tu as dis ça non
non et maintenant ça tu charries parce
que le viol le viol est un truc
profondément décalage je trouve ça
ignoble
quand tu vois liliane
il y en a vraiment été traumatisée par
titre alors ça dégueulasse
ceux-ci des jeux mais aussi un peu la
place de son violeur je vais me faire
l'avocat du diable
le gars dans sa voiture le soir elle est
belle liliane c'est une belle fille donc
elle le cherche
je les femmes le cher je ne me fais pas
dire ça elle ne cherche pas à les aimer
ça non écoute chômage elle ne cherche
même pas ça mais c'est la nature qu'est
ce que tu veux une femme est
femmes non mais je veux pas te raconter
une histoire de viol c'est là n'est pas
question c'est une histoire de viol qui
m'intéresse ce sont les conséquences
enfin ça bien commencer un jour oui je
faisais du stop à la porte d'orléans et
j'allais à nîmes pour faire là-bas stage
d'archéologie juste après juste au
moment des vacances au début des
vacances
pourquoi tu veux je te raconte ça se
comprend pas non j'ai pas envie j'ai
envie de me remémorer tout ça je sais
pas où ça nous mène et tous âges
le procès qui a duré
déjà le procès en assises tellement
d'heures qui a rien à bordés de la
vérité je veux pas tout recommencer
cette histoire c'est dans le dossier ça
n'a rien donné et je vais pas
recommencer ça je fais part a raconté de
nouveau et tout ça bon déjà pourquoi tu
as du staff y avait quand même eu une
raison pourquoi je faisais du stop
voilà c'était proprement utilitaires et
je n'avais pas d'argent j'étais
étudiante et j'avais une bourse de 100
francs par mois pour vivre complètement
6 il me faut des justifications mais en
plus on peut faire du stop par plaisir
par le goût des voyages parce qu'on aime
la vie on n'aime pas la recherche d'une
aventure sexuelle par exemple c'est ce
qui se dit pourtant c'est ce qui se dit
oui ce qui s'y dit encore cédant temps
c'est dont on soupçonne ceux dont on
soupçonne les auto stoppeuse tout le
temps qui leur arrive
pépin l'ont bien cherché pourquoi on se
méfie pas dans la vie pourquoi on n'est
pas plus prudent pourquoi on n'est pas
toujours dans la crainte des autres qui
on va ou de vendre ça on est potable
n'attendez pas trop nantes a un petit
peu
le temps que j'attendais ça fait 20
minutes vous choisissez votre votre
chauffeur le visa on prendra part au
monde paru aussi aussi peut-être pas
très notre choix déjà on garde la tête
problème pas moi je n'ai jamais vu
moi non plus mais récemment on a entendu
dire qu'il ya une autonomie de stopper
des faits violé la justice avait rejeté
la faute sur elle sans qu'
tout était de sa faute
je suis pas du tout fan
personnellement je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec ta justice qu'on voit
quand on se prend dans ce top on cite
pas chouette on va se faire virer
prenez quand même des riches car oui
c'était un premier sera toujours des
risques façon même si on se balade seul
quand même
en fait du stop je pense pas contente
buteur à nouveau et ça dépend de la
mentalité du thé toute façon une poste
peu ce qui se fait violer n'a que ce
qu'elle mérite
c'est la conclusion que l'on tire d'une
récente décision de la cour d'appel de
colmar qui réduisit de moitié la peine
de prison d'un automobiliste violeur à
notre avis celui du président ullmann de
la cour d'assises de paris
question difficile en ce qui concerne
les auto stoppeuse il est évident qu'on
ne peut pas supprimer l'auto-stop
alors il faut considérer c'est un fait
qui existe à l'heure actuelle on fait
appel aux automobilistes de bonne
volonté pour être transportés mais je
pense que dans l'appréciation de la
peine qu'il convient d'appliquer à
l'auteur d'un viol au préjudice d'une
auto-stoppeuse faut tenir compte du fait
que cette victime a pris un risque en
montant dans une voiture avec un garçon
qu'elle ne connaissait pas et puisque
chaque fois il faut apprécier tous les
éléments d'une cause pour apprécier la
peine qu'il convient d'appliquer on peut
faire la comparaison avec alain
automobilistes qui passent en sur une
route à l'écart d'une agglomération
aperçoit une jeune fille qui dont la
silhouette puis blake qui se précipitent
sur elle et qui la viole dans un box aux
voisins il est certain que
la peine qu'il convient d'appliquer doit
être plus forte pour celui qui n'a pas
été preuve qu'il n'a pas été provoquée
il est certain que l'attitude de la
victime doit entrer également en ligne
de compte
vous parlez de provocation c'est une
provocation indirect si vous voulez il
est certain que les hommes sont ce
qu'ils sont qu'il faut éviter par
exemple je reprends cet exploit
d'allumer puisque c'est l'expérience
un garçon et puis après de faire machine
arrière après avoir laissé espérer une
issue j'ose dire favorables alors on
peut penser que le garçon vit dans un
état d'exaspération ce qui n'excuse rien
mais qui peut entrer en ligne de compte
dans l'appréciation de la peine qu'il
convient d'appliquer
comment ça s'est passé après après ton
violent qu'est ce que tu as fait tu as
réagi tout de suite il y avait le faire
une déposition porter plainte
comment il a fallu fait il a fallu tu as
choisis tu l'a pas choisi j'étais perdu
dans la nature révolté pas envie de
vivre mais révoltée dégoûté vraiment
besoin de justice besoin de comprendre
besoin besoin des deux qu'est-ce que je
peux faire je vais chez les flics qui a
rien d'autre
j'ai pas d'amis je connais personne tu
sais les flics je veux retrouver le type
c'est important pour toi de le retrouver
de retrouver le type oui pourquoi il ya
que lui qui
il ya que lui qui aurait pu dire devant
la justice
c'est quand même lui qui est la cause de
ma révolte 1 sél ville le noeud du
problème et besoin de vengeance besoin
de tenir le tenir je sais pas pourquoi
pour lui demander des comptes c'est ce
que je pensais était perdu dans la
nature je pensais encore j'avais
l'illusion qu'on puisse le retrouver là
quelque part dans ce pays c'est parce
que j'ai trouvé chez les flics quand je
suis arrivé moi chez les gendarmes
avallon au petit jour là j'ai retiré ma
plainte parce qu'ils n'ont fait que
m'agresser et tous a menacé de prévenir
ma mère tout de suite comme ça je leur
expliquais que j'avais des frères et
soeurs plus jeunes que moi et je leur
dise pas possible comme ça de la
prévenir et tout et puis j'ai été
agressée immédiatement contrôle de
papiers ce que je suis pas en fut que
ceci cela alors que j'étais campagne
mines candidement déconfite et chialer
tu leur avait dit que c'était leur envie
c'était que tu avais été prise pour une
voiture
ah oui oui la réduction si t as te pose
alors j'ai demandé si je pouvais retirer
ma plainte parce que c'était vraiment du
terrorisme là que j'avais en face de moi
et m'ont dit oui bien sûr est-ce que je
peux la reporter chez moi alors je vais
aller voir ma mère c'est moi qui vais
lui parler tranquillement
d'abord j'ai pas pu lui dire tout de
suite c'était très dur de rentrer chez
moi dans l'état où j'étais et sur les
trois jours chez des amis avant de
rentrer chez ma mère quand j'ai réussi à
parler à ma mère dans la nuit
ma mère était était électrique et le
gars était d'accord pour reporter ma
plainte avec moi et tout de suite elle
était d'accord pour foncer avec moi ça
allait coûter de l'argent mais elle
aurait donné tout ce qu'elle avait aussi
ont fait pendant trois mois vraiment
j'avais sur le fantasme de le tenir et
et le zigouiller lui flinguer le zizi
oui j'aurais voulu qu'ils vraiment
qu'ils sentent salle au oui non mais je
crois pas qu'ils croient pas il ya
aucune issue satisfaisante à ce genre de
violence monsieur le président quelle
est votre définition du viol
je n'ai pas à proprement parler ma
propre définition du viol je ne peux que
vous donnez celle qui a été donné dans
un arrêt de la cour de cassation à
savoir qu'il consiste dans le fait
d'avoir des relations sexuelles avec une
femme contre la volonté de celle-ci et
pour être plus complet dire que le
beagle résulte de violences physiques
soit de tout autre moyen de contrainte
ou deux surprises voilà la définition
qui a été donné par la cour de cassation
est ce un crime ou un délit c'est un
crime c'est un crime mais pour faciliter
la l'instruction des affaires et le
passage de cette affaire devant les
juridictions répressives fonctionne
comme pour tous les autres crimes
d'ailleurs la correctionnalisation si on
essaye de faire passer le maximum
d'affaires les moins graves bien entendu
devant le tribunal correctionnel en
transformant le crime de viol en un
outrage public à la pudeur
depuis la sphère des deux belges violée
à marseille les avocats de la partie
civile plaident la compétence des
tribunaux correctionnels pour juger le
crime de viol un crime par définition
passe en cour d'assises
m et les unit l'expliquent je crois que
ce que l'âge la femme qui a été violée
veux avant tout c'est qu'on reconnaisse
qu'elle a été victime d'un véritable
crime qu'elle a été victime d'un viol et
je crois que c'est lui a infligé un
nouveau viol au nom du peuple français
tout entier parce que la justice est
rendue au nom du peuple français tout
entier que de qualifier les faits dont
elle a été victime de délits de coups et
blessures c'est encore une fois
minimiser le crime de viol il faut que
ce genre de faits soit jugé par la cour
et 6 prises dans la machine judiciaire
d'instruction en correctionnelle de cour
d'appel en a six
liliane pendant sept ans revivre à ce
qu'elle voulait à tout prix oublier son
viol en 1974 au bord de la dépression
liliane quitte paris elle s'installe
dans une ferme abandonnée en haute
provence sans électricité sans eau
courante
ce retour à la nature et le soutien des
avocats de sos femmes lors de son procès
d'assises lui font prendre le dessus
né de la ligue du droit des femmes créée
en 1974
sos femmes aide matériellement et
psychologiquement les femmes battues et
violées à leur actif déjà de nombreux
procès féministe et la recherche d'une
nouvelle définition du viol car sachez
entre autres une femme ne peut être
violée par son mari et que la
sonorisation n'est pas un viol briscard
son code pénal à noter écrit le viol
c'est l'introduction illicite et forcé
du pénis de l'homme dans le sexe de la
femme
ouais alors c'est est extrêmement dp
définition comme ça sont extrêmement
grave dans la mesure où on s'est
interrogé sur le point de savoir s'il ya
un homme qui a produit the une pompe à
vélo dans le sexe d'une femme pouvait
être poursuivi pour viol ce qui signifie
qu'actuellement le viol est
effectivement un droit un crime mais il
appartient à la victime de prouver d'une
part qu'elle a été violée
d'autre part qu'elle n'était pas
consentante et à ce niveau là
véritablement ces scandales c'est
scandaleux parce qu'on exige
littéralement une double preuve au
surplus on exige de la victime qu'elle
apporte
oui vraiment la preuve qu'à aucun moment
elle n'a voulu cela or nous avons eu des
cas dans lequel la femme me disais bien
sûr je ne suis pas consentante mais je
préfère encore avoir été violée plutôt
que d'être morte cela était inscrit dans
le procès verbal l'instruction et on en
a tiré une circonstance atténuante
on pour disqualifier cela en violences
envoyez parce que étant donné qu'elle
avait eu la lucidité cette malheureuse
victime de 10 oui je préfère avoir été
violée plutôt morte c'est qu'on sent
certainement
c'est une violence elle avait était
consentante est ce que tu t'es senti une
fois coupable mais j'étais pas seulement
un temps non je me suis jamais senti
coupable
jamais j'étais absolument sûr j'aurais
pu succomber où je sais pas mais finir
par consentir à un moment quelconque
sentir à ce titre un peu coupable mais
non jamais jamais absolument jamais non
jamais oui les femmes sont toujours
coupable enfin en matière de viol on
voit que c'est le seul crime où la
victime est traitée en accuser elle sera
mythomane elle sera perverse elle
racontera n'importe quoi elle aura
provoqué l'homme
peut-être même que six cd possible ce
serait elle qui violerait l'homme cet
après midi j'avais à défendre le cas
d'une jeune mineure qui a été violée
pour moi il me semble que son cas ne
faisait aucun doute
et pourtant on a dit de l'autre côté de
la barre que d'une part elle était
consentante qu'elle avait provoqué son
agresseur enfin tous les arguments et
qu'on a entendues jusqu'à présent elle
avait 15 ans elle avait 15 ans et on a
dit que vis-à-vis de son agresseur des
rapports de force étaient inégaux que
c'était elle qui était la plus forte
enfin ça c'est ce qui a été dit du côté
de la défense mais enfin je pense que
c'est absolument scandaleux c'est le
problème du viol c'est c'est là le
problème
pour s'assurer de la sincérité de la
présumée victime pour mesurer le degré
du traumatisme sur le plan psychique et
sexuelle les tribunaux s'adresse à
l'expert psychiatre cet examen de
crédibilité ressentie par les femmes
violées comme un nouveau viol mais c'est
pas un violon les forces base si elles
veulent se taire les m'est arrivé
d'avoir des filles qui refusent de
parler
bon bah le refuse de parler en prend
acte que elle préfère ne pas reparler de
circonstance et puis se terminer quel
est le but de cet examen qui cet
interrogatoire de cet examen
généralement il ya deux si vous voulez
les magistrats cherche deux choses la
première c'est si il y a un
retentissement durable sur le psychisme
de l'intéressé et il peut y en avoir de
très grave
et puis quelquefois ça dépend des
circonstances dans lesquelles les choses
en plus lieu où on peut se poser la
question de la sincérité de la
crédibilité des propos de la victime ou
supposés tels
vous savez il ya des tas de sorte de
viol en quelque sorte si vous voulez si
vous prenez l'exemple d'un vrai viol bon
une histoire vraie une fille saison
rentrer chez elle du cours le soir en
mobylette dans une banlieue parisienne
trois gars sort d'une maison
construction se précipite sur elle la
renverse la roue de coups l'entraînent
dans la maison et la viole ça c'est un
viol
ingrandes est stable les circonstances
sont telles qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
qualifications un geste paraît que celui
de viol ce qui est un crime mais va donc
aux assiste bien mais vous avez des tas
d'autres circonstances où on peut se
demander s'il affiche qu à quel point la
fille n'est pas consentante ce qui
arrive par exemple dans des violences en
bandes ou quelquefois elle est
consentante pour un qui est son petit
ami habituel et puis les copains sont
venus derrière et entreprennent de
passer ou bien
dans d'autres circonstances où vous avez
des accusations par exemple qui se
révèle parfaitement calomnieuse est
arrivé avec une fillette dont je me
souviens qu'il devra dizaine d'années à
peu près qui avait accusé son oncle de
l'avoir violée m'ont tous les détails
étaient avec ce luxe merveilleuses
détail nantes on dit c'est pas possible
qu'elle était inventé ça cette petite
bien vous aurait-elle été chercher ça
pleut le viol était censé se passer dans
une voiture d'à ces petits formats en
principe on entend l'oncle et on
découvre que ce type est un obèse
vraiment très considérable qui devait
être complètement coincé contre son
volant et que ce que la gamine décrivait
n'était matériellement pas possible donc
dans le rapport on dit que généralement
la formule qu'on en place et que les
propos de la personne ou de l'enfant
doivent être pris avec le maximum de
prudence et être recoupés avec précision
par des faits exacts et prouver est-ce
que l'on peut parler de portrait type de
la femme violée ou de la fille violée
non pas parce que bon il ya d'abord tous
les âges ça commence très très tôt ce
que j'aimerais à faire mon ami la fois
il ya des années un gars qui avait violé
sa fille qui avait huit mois de même
qu'on voit violé des très vieille femme
ça peut arriver aussi
ce sont souvent si vous leur en dehors
du viol
raptus comme ça ou du viol consentant ce
sont souvent des filles c'est fragile
personnalité assez faible peureux
le crime de viol est puni de dix à vingt
ans de prison
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais reconnu son acte tu as
beaucoup on mettait ce que tu aurais
bien lui ça soit classée rapidement
n'ont de toute façon et je me doutais
bien qu'il allait se défendre d'une
façon ou d'une autre
non oui enfin un violeur reconnaît pas
son lac comme ça ou alors il dit est bon
consentement ça veut dire je suis pas
coupable de quoi s plein maintenant je
leur reconnais jamais les violeurs pour
lui c'est une relation normale
maintenant je comprends ça je prends ça
comme il me disait bon après m'avoir
violée il était presque gentil avec moi
il essayait de dire sa vie sentimentale
malheureuse de misère tout ça et je
voulais pas l'entendre mais c'est
évident que ça le déculpabiliser comme
s'il m'avait pas violer comme si je
pouvais être à côté de lui il allait
coûter presque satisfaite violeur pour
gm et qui violent c'est normal c'est
normal comme alors qu'il était sur moi
et moi à me débattre il me dit alors
fait pas la gamine sinon je te viole
sais pas ce que ça veut dire violer
alors si c'est pas ça qu'il était déjà
en train de faire trois ans de prison
avec sursis pour le violeur de liliane
c'est la rigolade
qu'est ce que ça veut dire parce que tu
aurais préféré qu il n'est rien du tout
qu'il est une peine plus importante
hausse et pas sur les résultats que
j'aurais eu des préférences quelque
chose à redire c'est dans la façon dont
ça s'est déroulé
les résultats je suis à peu près c'est
satisfaisant se voulait pas de peine
pour le grand pat fry que c'était pas ça
quand elle justification justification
de quoi que le jugement justifie ta
position de deux filles qui n'a pas
cherché le viol de violer sa vieux
soient reconnus mais le fils sage je
sais pas si c'est une fille ça et c'est
pas mon souci en principe et ça ne
devrait pas se réparer sous forme du
versement d'une somme
et puis tout dépend du préjudice le lait
les cas sont tellement différents entre
le viol d'une jeune fille âgée de moins
de 15
d'une jeune fille qui n'a jamais connu
l'amour tout ça ce sont des différences
qu'il convient d'apprécier
il ya des femmes qui ont été violées qui
ne subissent aucun traumatisme physique
ou morale et en actes toute leur vie
sont traumatisés car la façon dont élan
ils ont connu leurs rapports avec
l'homme
elles sont en reste marquée pour toute
leur existence elle risque d'être
vraiment d'avoir une vie obérée par ce
tract qui s'est produit dans leur
jeunesse
alors c'est très grave et c'est cette
gravité qu'il convient d'évaluer au
moment où on prononce la sanction c'est
très très difficile c'est une matière
vraiment très divisés pour apprécier
pour la sanction nous avocats de la
ville lui aura des phares nous répondons
que nous nous en moquons complètement
que de la peine très lourde qu'un
violeur ne s'améliorera pas en prison
que par contre ce qu'il faut faire
évoluer ce qu'il faut faire changer ce
sont les mentalités
il faut les faire changer à deux niveaux
au niveau de la victime d'abord ce que
la victime elle se situe toujours par
rapport à l'homme et ça il faut qu'elle
apprenne peu à peu progressivement à se
situer en tant que femme
ce qui est extrêmement difficile puisque
dès le jardin enfant on lui apprend
qu'elle est une petite fille que la main
en fait les courses et la cuisine et que
le papa il fait un métier intéressant
donc il faut lui apprendre se resituer
en tant que femme simplement en tant que
femme position de femme est pas et pas
facile c'est pas facile d'être une femme
est en plus un individu un humain à part
entière livre mais ce n'est pas non plus
très facile d'être un homme moi je crois
est ce que tout ça ce n'est pas aussi le
procès de la société
bien sûr c'est le procès de la société
et c'est ce que devrait dire la justice
en tout cas tout ce qu'on peut faire
c'est agir sur les causes sociales tout
ce qui encourage le viol bon c'est bien
connu la publicité la pornographie saint
michel qu'est ce qu'on pense qu'ils
avaient assis toi côté dale qu'est ce
que tu en penses toi 2 me descend à
faire jeudi sur son retable mais que
elle s'en est bien sorti du prétoire on
n'y a pas de question de benson sorti en
c'est malheureux que des gens en arriver
là parce que
pourquoi d'après toi mais parce que dans
la société dans laquelle on vit boulot
dodo et et je comprends que tu passes
dans une rue ou que tout bon bouquin
c'est une femme nue ou ou quelqu'un qui
embrasse une femme alors que toi tu es
dans ton petit coin dans ton petit lit
et et qui tu tues tu peux rien faire tu
dis bonjour à une fille le te dis merde
où tu me fais chier ou pas va draguer la
raison parce que tu finalement tu la
grèce qui s'est hissé de la violer je
comprends pas moi je comprends pas qu'on
prend à toi tu le comprends tu as déjà
eu une fois en vie ou une fois où
plusieurs fois envie d'y aller une femme
puis sûr qu'un homme j'ai toujours eu
des fantasmes
de faire l'amour avec telle ou telle
femme mais de là la violer je crois que
j'ai une certaine morale de respecter
l'être qui est en face de moi ici
s'il n'a pas envie de moi je n'ai pas
abusé à faire deux choses sans
consentement que je pense que c'est
évident qu'il faut agir sur les causes
sociales tout ce qui incite au viol à la
violence mais ça me ça me permet pas de
comprendre et d'expliquer le viol moi je
comprends pas ça me pose un problème
métaphysique les limites du libre
arbitre pour moi je suis convaincu que
tout le monde ne viole pas il ya des
hommes qui violeront jamais j'en suis
convaincu il ya des hommes qui viole pas
et qu'ils pourraient violer
[Musique]
celui là il devra être en garde principe
apparu petit alors
s'il vous plaît est ce que vous savez
qu'une tous deux prennent des risques en
montant avec un chauffeur tête bien avec
un conducteur de voiture mon chauffeur
routier qui fait la route toute sa vie
les pères de famille ils ramassent deux
filles lapin aux autres s'amusent à 16
mois à l'intention de faire une
compagnie sur la route de bercy
[Musique]